on your page on your page what I want
you to do actually I'm gonna pass these
around soon I want you to draw a
triangle and triangle in fact I've
purposely once you draw triangle it's
different to the person next to you
chart about like you know and sighs I
mean it's kind of a decent size right
draw that triangle you can have acute
angles of tus angles it can be right
angle anything you like but I do want it
to be different from the person next to
you try and grow it a little bit
randomly by the way some of you might
accidentally draw a ladder triangle or
an isosceles triangle
if you accidentally do that that's
totally okay in fact the point that
we're going to make be interesting if
you've got yours as well right so like I
said measure out all the angles and give
me some lengths to make sure at all
those sides and give me those lengths
just to the nearest millimeter would be
great okay now I'll ask you why how
could you add them up and get a hundred
eighty one degrees any one things a real
answer to that how can you measure all
the egg was Adam up and then not 180
like they're supposed to me well like
it's just like you're trying goes wrong
by these sorry okay
um generally what's happening is I'm
just gonna borrow this you guys remember
from a couple years back probably when
we talk about measuring things whether
their angles or distances and we talk
about the limits of accuracy the limits
of accuracy so for instance the closest
that this thing can measure is a whole
degree right that's why that's one of
the markings are 180 degrees all the way
around here so if you've got an angle
that's not exactly a whole number then
you're forced to approximate right you
might approximate up we might
approximating down now if there are a
couple of angles and you approximate
both of them up because it's like well
that's the closest team when you add
them you're gonna get more than 180
degrees because you've approximate up
with okay so it's okay that's kind of
just
they forget the distances give me a show
of hands if you've done all your angles
and we sighs hands up
yeah cool all right that's enough let's
move on if you're still going that's
okay just listen as you're doing that
what you should have is something that
looks roughly like this okay well
actually I take that back you also would
nothing like this probably because I've
asked you all to Georgian training once
but the feature I'm about to point out
to you on my triangle you should be able
to point out on yours okay you can see
probably our most of you one of your
angles is bigger than the other two
right so you have its biggest angle if
you've got an isosceles triangle or any
collateral one you might not see that
now my you can see is 121 degrees
there's my biggest angle now I want you
to pay attention to the fact that this
biggest angle is opposite the biggest
side in the triangle do you see that
that's opposites anyone in my triangle
which is clearly the longest side and
you have a look at yours
look at the biggest angle and look at
the side that's opposite it facing in it
and it should also have been the side
that you measured out was the longest
okay correspondingly if you have a look
at the smallest angle this lost angle it
should also be opposite the smallest
sign okay the smaller side and the
smallest angle will be opposite each
other and it has to be this way right
because if you think about it if you
just um have a pair of random sides
right a pair of random sides and you
take this angle in here between them
what we call the included angle right if
you were to take those two and widen
them increase the angle between them
you're necessarily increasing the length
of this side that joins them
you see that this red length over here
will get bigger and bigger and bigger
as the angle that defines it gets wider
wider and wider
okay so let's just quickly jot this down
right and by the way if you've noticed
for example those of you created an
equilateral triangle by accident okay
because all your angles are equal
you've made all your sides equal as well
or if you made nice sausage triangle by
accident if you've got two equal angles
then those are clearly available if you
have two equal angles then the sides
opposite then are also right there's a
clear relationship going on here let's
write this down right in a triangle we
started with the longest side the
longest side is always opposite the
largest angle
innatron along sides always obvious with
the largest angle the same is true for
the smallest sight and it's true for the
longest side and the shortest side it
must be true for my side that's left
over right and you can take the same
pattern if angles are equal the sites
that are opposite them are also equal so
this kind of thing seems like cannon
fodder for understanding and using the
trigonometric ratios to understand
what's going on okay now we want to use
trigonometry to try to formalize this
relationship okay but the problem with
doing that is that you're now triangle
all the triangles you've drawn unless
you've done this coincidentally none of
them are right angle right there not
right angle triangles and trigonometry
so cause until they start in running
trains and I don't have any right angles
here okay but you guys know from my
freaking this guy you guys know that
even where no right-angled triangles
appear they are still riding the train
goes kind of hiding in there right like
this guy and there are sure enough right
angle trails highly in all of the
triangles you have gone okay
all you have to do to show them and I'll
ask you to construct this just on yours
if you have a different color that would
be awesome
take that biggest angle that biggest
angle right and I'm going to actually
draw a line from that point to that
opposite side the longest side but he's
the side I want you to draw the line on
zero once you transform out it's you and
how's that she looks like this it's
perpendicular to the sign that it
connects to okay so it goes from that
biggest angle to the biggest sign but it
does so in such a way that it's
perpendicular right like if I went off
at a different angle I'd get some other
range but um I will let the elta to you
or you can put it this way that's the
perpendicular height now once you've
done that and we're gonna do this in a
brand new triangle Center with all of
this
because otherwise it's gonna get a bit
confusing in a second once you've done
that you see what started we mowed my
tables I now have to mine a new
triangles hiding they're right next to
each other okay and they're the ones
we're going to use so now that your
content is we can take any triangle we
like and we can put right angle
triangles in it Makia let's all throw
the same right angle triangle so that
you can follow that point one go look
something like this